the white house strategy is not working
that statement could apply to
basically any area of public policy the
economy immigration crime education
certainly foreign policy but it is
especially true
of ukraine
which joe biden and company have botched
every single step of the way for years
going all the way back to the time that
joe biden was vice president and the
point man on ukraine so when kamala
harris was asked this week what the
biden administration planned to do
differently moving forward you might
have expected them to offer at least i
don't know one or two suggestions
but you would be wrong
despite failure after failure
after catastrophic failure
the white house plans to change
nothing
so what else do we have to throw at this
when putin so far is undeterred
well we are gonna continue to do what
we've done
they're gonna they're gonna continue to
do what they've done exactly
what they are already
doing
which hasn't worked just like the last
time kamala was asked about changing a
failed strategy
at what point does the administration
say you know what this strategy isn't
working we're going to change studies
six former
administration officials last week wrote
that open letter urging the
administration to change course to
change strategy
is it time
it is time for us to
do what we have been doing and that time
is every day
every day it is time for us to agree
that
there are things and tools that are
available to us to slow this thing down
inspiring it is time mr gorbachev tear
down this wall it is time we have
nothing to fear but fear itself it is
time
for us to be doing
what we have been doing and that time
is every day the white house remains
confident that in the long run
their strategy which has never worked
is going to work kamala harris is just
as confident today
of their strategy to stop the russian
war in ukraine as she was six weeks ago
that the war would never start in the
first place
i will repeat myself
and i'm vice president of the united
states and the president and i
work closely together and i know his
position because he has been consistent
in that regard
if vladimir putin and russia takes
aggressive action
it will be met with a cost that will be
severe
it will of course it it wasn't it
happened it wasn't they have no
credibility but joe biden's been
consistent he has been consistent don't
worry it'll work this time the white
house strategy and the definition of
madness doing the same things over and
over and over again
and expecting different results i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from wyvm
who says the biggest flex
would be if you told someone that
michael knowles picked your comment as
his favorite comment yesterday well now
wyvm you get that flex so can all of you
please give me your most entertaining
most delightful comments i look for it's
a little glimmer of light when i wake up
in the morning
and uh congratulations to you on your
big flex
w-y-v-m it's wonderful okay we're living
in a time that's just
it's it brings you down it's just full
of muck it's just filthy it's dirty and
when when you want a clean slate i would
really recommend you check out naturally
it's clean right now go to
naturalanceclean.com
michael and use code michael this is my
absolute favorite cleaning product ever
and i've got a very messy little baby
boy at home who
requires me to use this product a lot
and i'm really glad that we have a
hospital grade cleaning product
at home that will not leave harmful
chemicals on all of our surfaces that is
naturally it's clean a home cleaning
company dedicated to providing the most
effective cleaning products for your
home
while reducing the use of harmful
chemicals you would think that those
things would be in contrast right so you
would either have a very effective
cleaning product or you could avoid the
harmful chemicals but naturally it's
clean does both the way they do it is
with powerful plant-based enzymes
nature's solution to cleaning so you're
not just pushing the muck around you're
actually going in with hospital grade
enzyme cleaning power breaking down that
muck
try it for yourself right now our
listeners can get their hands on the
naturally it's clean daily wire
essential kit stocked with four great
products for fifteen percent off go to
naturallyitsclean.com michael use promo
code michael that is a wonderful way to
start cleaning your home 15 off by
visiting naturaleatsclean.com
michael mich ael promo code michael the
biden administration does not have time
to change its strategy on the economy
which has failed its threat and they're
lying about the economy too they're
saying joe biden's created more jobs
than anybody that's not true even the
new york times is now admitting in a
fact check that that's not true
what happened was at the end of the
trump administration all of the
liberal ruling class establishment
intentionally shut down all of the jobs
for the kovid 19 thing and they shut
them down and then joe biden gets into
office and they say okay you can let up
again and so obviously if you get rid of
all the jobs then some jobs are going to
come back but the jobs haven't reached
pre-pandemic levels so joe biden on the
economy on jobs is a failure on crime
total failure crime is spiking it's
through the roof on immigration we've
got the worst immigration numbers ever
in the history of the united states
illegal immigration what did we have two
million illegal immigrants crossed that
border last year we've never seen
anything like that
in in recent memory
so and foreign policy goes without
saying foreign policy has been a total
disaster so they can't they can't
address any of their failed strategies
on that because they're too busy they're
focused on the really important issues
not the economy not immigration not
crime not foreign policy they're
focusing on
transiting the kids
that's that is priority number one for
the biden administration he talked about
it during the state of the union it's
the only area of policy where he is
taking new and aggressive action right
now even as the rest of the country
collapses why is he doing that because
texas
is doing a very good thing in texas
right now good old republican state
texas is going after parents who are
abusing their children by mutilating
their genitals and pumping them full of
hormones to convince little boys that
they're little girls
there's a story about this right now in
the new york times
new york times headline texas
investigates parents over care for
transgender youth suit says over care
how are they caring for their
transgender youth by mutilating their
bodies and pumping them full of poison
the investigations by the state
department of family and protective
services started last week with an
employee of the agency according to the
suit after governor greg abbott called
for such
inquiries
so
in texas you are not allowed to trans
your kids
which is a good thing it's a good thing
for the kids it's not good to mutilate
the little the bodies of little kids
it's a good thing for
society it's a it's a really sick
perverted society unjust society that
mutilates little kids because of sexual
fads and fashions that have been around
for approximately five minutes it's
really good for the rule of law
and the new york times is furious the
libs are furious they are so
insistent
that we trans the freaking kids they're
trying to put it into federal law
they're trying to put it into the civil
rights act they're trying to put it
they're reading it into supreme court
decisions they're they're focusing on it
as a presidential
priority
to go in
and tell texas parents that they have
the right
to chop up their kids
it's creepy it's creepy and weird it's a
weird obsession
the transgenderism craze has only been
around for what five or ten years at
this point
it's been basically the minute that the
libs succeeded at radically redefining
marriage all of their radical sexual
apparatus just moved on to
transgenderism which is kind of ironic
because it totally undermines the
argument for homosexuality right the
argument the argument for gay marriage
was look people are born this way they
can't change who they love they can't
change their sexual desires
but when boys are boys and the boys are
attracted to other boys then there's no
way for the boys not to pursue their
romantic love for other boys and that's
why we need to redefine marriage also
there's no such thing as boys
also there's no such thing as girls
also a boy can become a girl but never
mind moving on moving on nothing to see
here so it was totally incoherent but
they've really gone all in on it and now
the biden administration
is is doubling down and they're saying
no you will you will trans the kids joe
biden and his
hhs secretary
xavier becerra have come out and said
this is going to be a major fight for
our administration joe biden said quote
affirming a transgender child's identity
is one of the best things a parent a
teacher or a doctor can do to help keep
children from harm
and parents who love and affirm their
children should be applauded and
supported not threatened investigated or
stigmatized i totally agree with that
i 100 agree with that
it is very important to affirm a
transgender child's identity
transgender children for instance boys
who think they're girls
are boys it's really important to affirm
their true identity as boys it does not
help them to indulge the delusion or the
sexual fetish or the fantasy that they
are girls or something else or not boys
or girls or some 57th gender that
doesn't help them at all
we've gone through the statistics many
times on the show
but there isn't no real evidence that
having some mutilation surgery reduces
rates of anxiety depression or suicide
among sexually confused people who think
that the opposite sex there's no
evidence of that whatsoever
there is no
there is actually a lot of evidence that
if you just
tell your little boy no you actually are
a boy you tell your little girl no you
actually are a little girl that
eventually
in at least a large number of cases the
delusion the dysphoria goes away
so it is much much better
to tell your child no look we love you i
know you're going through this tough
thing i know you've you're experiencing
this hard problem right now but you
really are a boy don't don't run away
with delusion now that's not what joe
biden means that's what his words
literally mean but the left always
twists words to try to mean their
opposite which was the topic of my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds which is going to be available in
paperback coming out in june
thank you to everyone who made it a
number one national bestseller in
hardcover it's coming out in paperback i
can't wait until it comes out and the
new york times snubs us again well too
bad you can pre-order your copy right
now
that's what the left tries to do that's
what joe biden is trying to do here
xavier becerra the hhs secretary says
the same thing he says the department of
health and human services is quote
committed to protecting young americans
who are targeted because of their sexual
orientation or gender identity
don't forget those two things are
contradictory
sexual orientation means
stuff about your sex can't change
gender identity means stuff about your
sex always can change and it must change
he says hhs says to evaluate the tools
at our disposal to protect trans and
gender diverse youth in texas good job
texas stand firm this is a very
important battle if it were just a minor
trivial issue the white house the entire
liberal establishment would not be going
all in on it stand firm this is one of
those issues on which civilization
itself rests if we can't tell the
difference between boys and girls we
can't tell anything
it's it's hard to tell very much of
anything at all in this it's hard to
tell what my dollar is worth these days
with
rampant inflation which is why you
really ought to check out birch gold
right now text knolls k-n-o-w-l-e-s
to 98 98 98
do it right away because our current
inflation is getting out of control
right now inflation looks like paying 47
percent more for fuel than one year ago
looks like paying 41 more for the same
used vehicle if you buy it this year
instead of last year those are insane
price hikes looks like paying almost 10
percent more to feed your family looks
like every dollar in your savings
account is worth less than it was a year
ago but you can hedge against the us
dollar by investing in something with
real value gold and silver from birch
gold
precious metals have historically been a
safe haven in times of inflation birch
gold is the leader in converting iras
and 401ks into a tax sheltered ira
backed by gold and silver they got
thousands of customers an a plus rating
from the better business bureau they can
help you protect your savings right now
text knowles canada wle yes to 98 98.98
to get a free info kit on gold every
second you wait your money is worth less
and less pull over if you need to stop
right now text knowles canada w l e
wles2989898 you will get a free info kit
do it now
ron desantis
just keeps the hits on coming uh the guy
is in terms of governors in this country
the guy is doing
better than basically anybody he i don't
know how he's obviously running for
president so he's gearing all of his
actions toward that but it's great it's
really working he had this is my
favorite desantis moment yet and it
happened just yesterday at the
university of south florida
governor desantis was going up to give a
little talk do a little photo line and
he sees students
wearing the stupid masks
and ron desantis he chose his words very
carefully i think
he corrected these students and it's a
correction that the entire country
should hear
you do not have to wear those masks i
mean please take care but honestly it's
not doing anything and we got to stop
with this code is theater so you want to
wear it fine but this is this is
ridiculous
all right well it's good to be at usf oh
it's good to be at usf it's good to see
rhonda descent and then what do the kids
do they take it off of course they take
it off they wanted to take this off the
whole time but people in authority these
petty little tyrants like their
professors and these
deputy deans of diversity and inclusion
that outrun all the campuses they won't
let them take it off but then in walks
mack daddy desantis and he says hey take
that off and what he said was was really
important he said a couple things that
were slightly different here
he said
if you want to wear it fine whatever
but then he said please take it off
we've i was thinking of all the various
there's more than just two reactions on
the masks right it's it's more than just
do wear the mask don't wear the
mask some people say do wear the mask
you must wear the mask wear the mask all
the time
some people say wear the mask if you
want to that's your individual choice
whatever you want to do is totally fine
because you have total control over your
body and you should never be made to
wear something or not wear something
that you don't want to wear it's totally
up to you if you want to look like a
bandito in society fine if you want to
walk around with some filthy cloth
covering your whole face no big deal
wear the secular cafe whatever you want
individualism baby and then there's the
conservative answer which is take off
the stupid mask it doesn't do anything
it's disordered for our society to have
everyone wandering around like they're
about to rob a stagecoach don't do it
take it off it's dumb it's weird it's
wrong and it's not how society should
function
and desantis he gave a little hint at
the kind of weak squishy individual do
whatever you want kind of argument in
the middle which was look if you want to
wear it whatever but most of his
argument was
please take it
off if it's beyond you don't need to
wear it you don't need to wear the mask
please take it off
please
we need to get past this coved theater
as long as there is a substantial
portion of americans wearing these
stupid masks we're not we're never going
to get past the covet theater
i'll give i'll give you an example of
this
my wife is a goes to certain classes
right
sweet little lazy you know she goes to
different classes sometimes with the
baby sometimes maybe it's an exercise
class this or that you've all seen this
in your own life too you go to a class
you go
to a community group you go to a meeting
no one wants to wear the mask
except for like one person like one
person
is sitting there and she's and and what
happens as a result of that one person
who wants to wear the mask everyone's
got to wear the mask okay is they're all
sitting there you've all got the dumb
masks on cause vouch you made us wear it
for two years and then you sit there and
you say okay and would it would people
feel comfortable if we do would you mind
if maybe we took the masks off and
everyone says oh actually yeah that
would be i maybe i would like and then
there's that one person who says
actually guys
i'm um i'm super duper
immunocompromised i'm
i have my great-great-grandmother-in-law
lives three towns over from us and i
might see her in six months so you could
you we all need to mask up forever
please
and people do it and they go it's that
it's the tyranny of the minority in all
of these things ben sometimes talks
about this with vegetarianism in
families everyone wants to eat meat in
your family everyone's having a nice
time oh good lamb chops oh yeah nice
steak that's great except that one then
there's
your little sister
your little sister decides to become a
vegetarian and oh no don't worry it's
just me it'll just be me the vegetarian
and what happens all of a sudden
no one eats meat anymore or your meat
consumption dramatically dries the
tyranny of the minority do not let them
get away with this
the masks are dumb they're stupid they
have no basis in
prudence or
sense or reason
drop them as a as a
cultural ritual they're hideous and
heinous all they remind me of is the
dictatorship of dr fatchi ditch him
desantis totally right
he's on a roll
he's on a roll this week
ron desantis last week
i meant to get to the store and we
didn't have time
but works just as well now
ron desantis was asked
to provide
florida national guard troops for the
state of the union address you remember
a couple weeks ago i said the libs for
the libs every single day is january 6th
and there's always an insurrection
around the corner and half the country
are nazis and bull conor and they're
going to attempt to overthrow the
government so they didn't just put up
the
fence around the capitol because of the
horn hat guy on january 6th because some
midwestern dads walked into the capital
rotunda in some cases with doors opened
for them by the police and cracked a
coors light and took some pictures and
that was supposed to be you know the war
of 1812 or something
no the the left did it because it helps
them to maintain power much like the
masks are a political symbol that
permits the left to maintain power the
the gate around the capital the fence
we're in dangerous times
don't claim too many of your rights or
liberties don't try to get back this is
not normal you don't get your normal way
of life because things are dangerous and
so one of the ways to do this they put
up the stupid fence around the capitol
for the state of the union and then they
they asked for national guard troops to
come back to washington dc so that
washington dc could become an actual
military-occupied city
for the second time in just one year
and they asked ron desantis and he said
no
he said no we're not we're not going to
do that
quote last week the biden administration
requested the assistance of state
national guards to deploy to washington
dc i've rejected this request there will
be no florida national guard sent to d.c
for biden state of the union absolutely
right and look biden's still alive well
he's as alive as he was before at least
he's allegedly alive he's at least being
propped up fairly fairly convincingly
he's fine
it was all good
they never needed to send the national
guard
it's theater
don't do it it's bad it's it's an ugly
thing for washington dc
to appear to be a military-occupied town
in perpetuity for it to look like
wartime baghdad all the time
i went last year
when
the national guard flooded dc
at the request of liberal democrat
politicians
i was there you know i flew in i fly
into dc a lot because i do the podcast
with senator cruz
and it's it's weird it doesn't it feels
un-american
for us to have troops stationed on every
corner all the time troops who don't
want to be there by the way they know
it's as ridiculous as we all do and
desantis is saying no he's offering
a different
vision not just of the state of florida
but of america because he's obviously
one of the people running for president
but if you think that desantis is just
the guy now
or even if you think trump is just the
guy now i don't think that's quite true
i think there are a lot of people who
are eyeing that
republican nomination in 2024. a lot of
people who could make a good claim at it
one of the people who's doing that
glenn younkin in virginia
glenn younkin just came out
to give the state the commonwealth of
virginia's view
on the war in ukraine
he said quote the invasion of ukraine by
soviet dictator vladimir putin cannot
stand and the people of the commonwealth
are ready to rally in opposition to this
senseless attack on a sovereign nation
in western ideals today we're acting to
show our solidarity with the ukrainian
people as they defend their country and
while these are important steps it is
incumbent upon president biden to take a
stronger more decisive leadership
position to end this war okay that's
fine that's nice of i'm sure we all
agree with the sentiment expressed in
that statement
the question is why is yunkan making
that statement
last i checked virginia doesn't have a
foreign policy
this is one of the issues that governors
have when they run for president is that
states don't have foreign policies
so virginia has really almost nothing to
say about the war in ukraine except that
glenn yunken
is probably eyeing the white house he is
at the very least eyeing the vice
presidency and frankly he would make a
pretty good candidate
don't
glenn juncken won in a blue state
that's that's pretty impressive
especially at a time when we are told
the suburban voters the suburban
housewives the the moderates they don't
like trump that much trump was too far
out there for them but republicans can
win on these issues especially parents
issues especially school boards and
critical race theory and transgenderism
in the classroom and oh exactly the
issues that got glenn younkin elected
that could be
a powerful ticket whoever it is
whoever's at the top of the ticket
whoever is at the bottom of the ticket
if you have a guy like yunkan it could
be pretty interesting the important
thing to remember here though because
what you're going to hear from a lot of
the establishment types is junkin he's a
moderate he's a centrist he's a fiscal
conservative he just talks about the
fiscal issues that's not true don't let
them rewrite history glenn younkin won
virginia on the social issues he was
going to lose virginia when he was just
a chamber of commerce economic candidate
he won on the social issues the social
issues so-called are winners for
republicans
there
there are are a lot of issues going on
in the country these days a lot of them
are appealing to can appeal to
get regular voters to vote for
republicans this is true on the social
side it's true on the foreign policy
side it's obviously true when you go to
fill up your gas tank this is basic
stuff which is why you got to check out
get upside thanks to the very stupid
policies of our ruling class gas is up
about seven bazillion percent right now
well if you want to get cash back every
time you fill up your tank go download
the free get upside app right now and
use promo code knowles when you go and
download from the app store from google
play store when you download the free
get upside app and you use promo code
knowles you can get 25 cents per gallon
or more on your first fill up cash back
there's no cash there's only cash back
the cash back gets added directly to
your bank account or it goes to
your paypal account or you get any gift
card to amazon or however you want to
get it i think the bank account is the
easiest way to do it it's a phenomenal
way you can also earn up to 30 cashback
at grocery stores restaurants food
delivery as well do it now download the
free get upside app use promo code
knowles kowles get 25 cents per gallon
or more cash back on your first tank
just use that promo code null skin wles
that is promo code knowles
you know the daily wire is making more
movies than like paramount at this point
we're just churning movies all the time
well we got a new movie coming out march
10th it's called hyperions
uh this movie does not follow the same
old hollywood prescribed formula it's a
movie that stands entirely on its own
and it's excellent check out the trailer
good day hyperion club members
[Music]
we've come for one thing
our titan badges this titan badge can
grant an individual superhuman power
perhaps it's time for someone else to
take on the responsibility
on my way
[Music]
she's trying to destroy me
we're going to be streaming this movie
once on march 10th for everyone on
youtube to see
then you've got to be a member to get in
on the action go to dailywire.com
subscribe so you don't miss any more of
the growing cache of content that we
have to offer also orlando magic player
jonathan isaac is publishing a book with
daily wire about the rise of his
basketball career his journey into faith
his strength to stand alone in the face
of immense social pressure the book's
available for pre-order now at amazon go
reserve your copy today we'll be right
back with a lot more
yesterday was ash wednesday ash
wednesday marks the beginning of lent a
penitential season
for all people really who consider
themselves christians especially for
catholics and how did our nominally
catholic president choose to
commemorate and and uh behave on ash
wednesday well he used the day to defend
killing babies
last night before
i tell you what
i don't want to get in a debate with you
on theology but you know well anyway
i'm not gonna i'm not i'm not gonna make
it i'm not going to make a judgment for
other people
i'm not going to make a judgment for
other people abortion is the one issue
where he won't he won't make a judgment
for other people and by the way of
course he's making a judgment he's
making the judgment that it's good to be
able to kill babies and he's not only
making that judgment by recognizing this
ridiculous supreme court decision roe
versus wade he's making that judgment
much firmer and more clearly because
he's saying we need to codify the roe
versus wade fictional right to abortion
into a federal law so of course he's
making a judgment
i love too how he opens he says well
look i'm not going to get into a debate
on theology yeah you probably won't
because it's not possible to be a
catholic and to support legal abortion
this isn't this isn't me throwing bombs
this isn't my political opinion and you
know it's in some controversial way it's
just simply a fact
it's it's delineated in the catechism of
the catholic church it's been catholic
teaching for 2 000 years
you you can't do it the reporter asked
that question how how can you support
abortion if you're a catholic well he
biden stumbles and mumbles and bumbles
over himself because it's a simple
answer you can't
you can't
and joe biden
has chosen
one religion over his nominal religion
he says he's a catholic
but when catholicism
runs up against leftism he chooses
leftism
when catholicism and liberalism or
leftism or progressivism where they seem
like they could maybe possibly be
reconciled then he doesn't have to make
the decision
well we should help the poor okay sure
something like that well we should
i don't know be compassionate okay well
there's something there okay
well we should kill babies nope that's
one where sorry your
your views have run up against the
catholic view and the catholic view by
the way is not just that we can all
debate this the catholic view is this is
a non-negotiable issue
if you
directly cooperate in abortion you incur
an excommunication automatically
you you cannot do this
okay
and
joe biden has chosen to now why has he
chosen to
in the past he has been a little more
conservative on abortion
you know he used to have the safe legal
and real rare perspective he used to say
i personally oppose abortion by publicly
defend abortion or he's changed his
views pretty much just whichever way the
political wind is moving in his party so
he has done it i don't think because of
any deep conviction i don't think biden
has any convictions at all he has done
it because he thinks that the social
issues are losers for conservatives and
winners for liberals
but they're not
just like on so many other issues biden
is wrong
his strategy here is not correct
this it may have been true 20 or 30
years ago the last time joe biden was
conscious but it's not true today
abortion is a winning issue for the
pro-life movement
okay it's a winning issue for
conservatives
transgenderism is a winning issue for
conservatives just ask governor younkin
critical race theory is a winning issue
for conservatives
again just ask governor younkin or a lot
of a lot of other candidates around the
country
democrats are crazy now part of the
reason they're doing this too is because
their base
has gone so all in on abortion and on
their on the social issues that they
really can't get out of it
because if they try to appease the
people in the middle and the
independents and the sort of normal
people they'll lose their base and
they'll lose elections and if they go
all in on their base they'll lose the
moderates and they'll lose elections
that's why their approval ratings are in
the 30s right now when they're not in
the 20s
but this was this was all it
comes this political problem for
democrats comes as it often does
from a
philosophical mistake a theoretical
mistake
years and years ago going back to
governor mario cuomo cuomo the first in
new york going back to people like
senator bob casey or governor bob casey
senior
of pennsylvania
you had democrats who were supposed to
be pro-life but their party was moving
in the
way of abortion they'd say well look i
personally oppose abortion
but politically i think everyone should
have that choice i you know that's the
choice i would make but you can make
whatever choice you want and this was
always incoherent it's like saying i
personally oppose murder but
politically you need to have the right
to commit a murder i personally oppose
armed robbery but politically you must
have the right to armed robbery it
doesn't make any sense and this this
neat and tidy way to totally separate
personal behavior and personal beliefs
from political beliefs
is
completely
outside the american tradition outside
the scope of a republic what is a
republic it's where we all come together
and we take our personal opinions of how
we view the world and we debate them and
we try to persuade our fellow americans
and then whoever has the strongest
argument persuades the most people wins
she it doesn't make any so you're
simultaneously going to make two
separate arguments
that are opposed to one another no of
course not
a house divided against itself cannot
stand so a democrat bob casey jr
bob casey senior son
just just made the same point
he just came out he's nominally catholic
but he doesn't hold what the church's
teaching on non-negotiable matters so
practically speaking he's not a
practicing catholic and bob casey senior
says that he's personally pro-life but
he just voted for this law the women's
health protection act quote unquote
which is just a baby butcher bill that
would ensconce the right to kill
children as a national right a federal
right
no one believes that he's doing it
because he he's willing to sell his soul
joe biden and bob casey are willing to
sell their souls for another chance at
re-election and the irony is they're
it's not going to help them politically
it'll it's going to hurt them
politically as is so often the case when
we sell our souls we think that it's a
really good deal because we get 30
pieces of silver we get a little fame we
get a little money we get a little we
get the hot woman we get the fast car we
get what we get this the things of this
world
but then what happens what happens with
every deal with the devil
it's a bum deal you don't you lose in
the end it was never worth it and that's
what we're seeing here it's so pathetic
it's so pathetic to watch guys who maybe
at some point in their lives
actually had integrity and belief and
and principle and kept their eyes on the
on the deeper things in life
on the really important things in life
selling out for what the the seal claps
and the defauling and applause of
of idiots and degenerates in their own
party who who probably are not even
going to be enough to carry them across
the finish line for a re-election
speaking of kids
there is some shocking
shocking news
to people who have not been paying
attention for two years this from the
new york times
turns out you know i know look i know
i just want to be very clear for youtube
and for big tech and everybody
the vaccines for covet are totally one
million percent safe and totally
effective and you can never get covet if
you get the vaccine and you can
certainly never transmit covid if you
get the vaccine unless and until dr
fauci and rochelle wolenski say you can
at which point they're allowed to say it
but i'm not allowed to admit it okay so
the vaccine the great the greatest thing
ever
the greatest thing since sliced bread
except
except this is weird the new york times
says
the pfizer shot
is far less effective in five to 11 year
olds than in older kids new data show
this is the next line this is still
right right below the headline while
protection against hospitalization is
still strong
the vaccine offered
almost no protection against infection
even just a month
after full vaccination of course there's
no such thing as full vaccination
because they keep adding shots for you
to take so you say full vaccination was
supposed to be one or two shots
then three
then four
now five it's gonna be six they're gonna
keep doing it
shocking shocking to people
who
still believe dr fauci
still trust the public health
establishment still
read the new york times not shocking
to any of us
the left has been telling us the
authorities the ruling class all the
geniuses have been saying we need to get
kids vaccinated we the teachers union
said we can't allow kids back to school
until they all get vaccinated
we the conservatives said the vaccines
aren't going to do very much for the
kids the kids are at statistically
almost no risk
of serious adverse side effects from the
coronavirus there's no evidence that the
vaccines are going to do very much to
the for the kids anyway though if the
point of the vaccines is to mitigate the
risk of hospitalization and death the
kids already have basically
an infinitesimally small risk of that if
it's to prevent transmission to older
people the vaccines just don't do that
to begin with so as the new york times
is even admitting here
and they said no you're a killer you're
all you're spreading this information
you're going to be censored you're going
to be shut up
you're going you're a murderer you're a
threat to the country until we admit
that you're right and we'll never give
you credit for it and we're still going
to keep you censored in many cases
but now just listen to what we're saying
today
this is why i got so angry at that snl
clip the snl did this sketch we played
it on the show yesterday where where
they it was all these liberals sitting
around and it actually summed up the
liberal behavior pretty well here which
is they're all wearing their you know or
one of them is wearing their masks they
say oh you can take off the mask we're
sitting at the table
and and he laughs keenan and thompson
says oh haha all right sometimes forget
when it's on my face
you know maybe
do maybe these not work that well they
said no never and they all obviously
believe that but no one wants to admit
it they're all terrified they all want
to seem as though they are totally
on board with dr fauci and michelle
balonsky and joe biden and hahahahaha
but oh i guess and the punchline of the
sketch was the masks don't really do
anything
wasn't that funny no that's not your
joke man that that's not funny because
we were saying that for two years and
you inflicted very real penalties on us
you censored us from a public square you
you
fired us from our jobs in some cases if
we wouldn't go along with this you
kicked us out of school if we wouldn't
go alone you've ruined people's lives
and now hahaha looks like they were
right
looks like they were right uh-huh okay
all that we can take away from this
is don't believe these people don't
believe fauci don't believe walensky
don't believe the new york times
don't believe big tech hold them
accountable when they censored us hold
them accountable when they tried to get
us fired investigate prosecute make it
hard for these people to do it again you
know the pr you want to know
the
100
rock solid proof
that that the kovid 19 scare is over
that it's
much less severe than than people ever
told us it was and that we can all go on
with our lives
the queen just survived kovid
the queen
who is one of my favorite people
left on earth i i just love her she's a
she it's not my country she's not the
head of my church she is a nice old
german lady i'm but i just she's just
great she's one of the last bastions of
dignity and sense and reason in the
world she's 95 years old
she was she was the queen reigning over
winston churchill and she gets covid
which is supposedly the most dangerous
scary disease in the history of the
world it's going to kill all the 10 year
olds and she survived after a few days
she had mild cold like symptoms
there was a news report in the united
kingdom of the the therapeutic drugs
that she was taking to treat kovid19 and
in the news report they showed that she
was taking ivermectin and which we were
all informed was horse dewormer and then
the propaganda ministers went into
overdrive they said no it was a mistake
we didn't mean to say it was like no no
please ignore pay no attention to the
man behind the curtain there's no
ivermectin even though previously we
said it was a wonder drug and the
discoverer of it won the nobel prize and
it's been prescribed to humans for years
no now it's a horse dewormer it never
happened but anyway regardless of
whatever drugs the queen was taking she
survived it's okay you're gonna live
you're gonna live and if you don't look
eventually you're gonna die that's kind
of the the
point of lent is to remember this is
what we heard yesterday on ash wednesday
remember man that you are dust and
industrial return so we're all going to
die someday
but there are a lot more things
on earth that pose a threat to you
than covid19
and you don't need to give up your jobs
and your lives and your family and your
friends and your life and your whole
freaking life in your political order
out of the
neurotic fear of covet 19. if the queen
can make it i have trust
in you
as well i love the queen so much in part
because although
as a matter of chronology
she is older than joe biden
significantly older than joe biden she
seems much more lucid much more with it
joe biden seems like he's about 150
years older than the queen
joe biden gave that rambling state of
the union
a couple of nights ago
he talked about all the important issues
he talked about how we need to trans the
kids
talked about that
he talked about he said go get him go
get him guys he talked that was
important he talked about
maternal health care how we need a
national law to kill babies in america
because right now we only have a bogus
supreme court decision that very likely
could be overturned so he found it was a
long speech he had there was a lot of
time
he didn't talk about one thing though
he didn't talk about the 13 american
service members who were killed in
afghanistan during his botched
withdrawal from that country and so
give credit to msnbc
uh jen saki the white house press
secretary went on msnbc yesterday she
was asked about this she said don't
don't you think maybe biden should have
mentioned the 13 service members in that
in the most significant foreign policy
issue of his administration including
ukraine which would be the pull out from
afghanistan her answer
there just wasn't enough time
so look a speech like the state of the
union it's hugely important it doesn't
touch on it doesn't have the time to
touch on everything that is a priority
they just didn't have the time because
they were spending too much time talking
about how we have to trans the kids
that's a much more important issue than
the 13 american servicemen who died
pulling out of the 20-year war that we
had in afghanistan after september 11
the most significant terror attack in
our nation's history that we didn't have
time to mention any of that
that doesn't really matter that's kind
of on the priority list that's a little
bit lower
when you can talk about important things
like transiting the kids but even saki's
excuse here doesn't hold water
because biden
did talk about it he didn't talk about
the service members of afghanistan
but he did talk about
american service members
being injured in the line of duty he
there was a whole segment of his speech
on that
he was talking about how service members
who are stationed near burn pits
sometimes get diseases and that's why we
need to treat those diseases because any
american who is harmed overseas needs
the fullest support of america unless
you're one of the 13 service members
killed on his watch in afghanistan then
you don't get a mention joe biden talked
about his son beau biden
who did not die he died he died of a
cancer but he didn't die in combat he
didn't die overseas and he mentioned his
son in the topic about service members
being injured but he couldn't mention
the 13 service members killed in the
attack in afghanistan in the in the poll
it was it's just so
offensive
it's so dishonest when gensake explains
it this way and it's it's just
gaslighting
it's j i guess that's what's so
i guess that that's the maybe the most
defensive part about it is not even what
he's doing but the fact that he won't
even acknowledge
the reality
and he won't let us acknowledge the
reality we all have to be living in this
pretend world speaking of pretend world
speaking of
body dysmorphia and as a national issue
we have to check in with our friends
libs of tick tock there is a tick tock
that has gone viral of a young
woman
describing the national epidemic
of fat phobia
let's talk about body preferences i've
heard a lot of talk like oh i don't hate
fat people
but
i'm not attracted to them and i don't
want to date them it's just my
preference
maybe
in an ideal circumstance
in a world that was forever body neutral
and did not demonize fat people
that could be a preference
maybe
but is there really such a thing
as preference in a society that
exclusively demonizes
an option
fat people are branded as disgusting
branded as something to be eliminated
unhygienic
lazy xyz everything else and we've
received that messaging since we were
born
our culture is deeply rooted and
entrenched in fatphobia chances are it's
not just a preference and you've just
been taught to think fat people are
gross
fat
phobia
everything is
a phobia
the line here that really caught my
attention is she said that we're taught
that fat people need to be eliminated
so what are you talking about not even
in the days of michelle obama who really
did seem to have a grudge against fat
people you know her big initiative in
the white house was was taking away
snacks from kids at lunch
taking away their little sweets in their
school lunches and making them eat
celery or whatever
but even in those days i don't think
anyone was calling for a genocide of fat
people do you remember that i don't
remember that then i thought what what
on earth could she mean but oh oh she
means
that people who are overweight are
encouraged to get into shape
that's what she means but then but
you're not being eliminated
you're just getting into shape
it's the same issue actually that we
have with the transgenderism
which is
the only way
that
fat people are being eliminated by being
encouraged to get into shape is if their
identity is fatness
which is a mistaken identity that's not
who you are if you're plenty of people
are overweight plenty of people
are have some issue with their bodies
right i guess basically everybody has
some issue with their bodies this is a
fallen world it's an imperfect world
sometimes we're just born that way you
got a thyroid condition you're a little
bit bigger sometimes through our own
habits we just we eat a little too much
we're a little slothful we don't work
out we don't and these are problems and
you can you can try to work on these and
you need to accept the natural limits of
a fallen world but okay maybe you can
improve so i know people have lost a lot
of weight and got into really good shape
when they were not in very good shape
before
it's not your identity
you
just like the transgender person is the
the identity of a man who thinks that
he's a woman
of stanley who thinks that he's sheila
his true identity is not sheila his true
identity is stanley
it's not the word phobia it means an
irrational fear
so you hear this about transphobia
all sorts of phobias
fat phobia it's not
not every
traditional preference is irrational
not every standard is
irrational it's not irrational to think
that a little boy who wants to become a
girl should not mutilate himself and
chop off his genitals that's not that's
actually rational to think that he
shouldn't do that
that's because there are standards we
can know things through reason
we can it's okay and and by the way to
have a standard doesn't mean that you're
saying that everyone who falls short of
that standard is evil all men sin and
fall short of the glory of god this is
an imperfect world but if we don't have
standards to stride toward standards of
the good the true and the beautiful not
the ugly and the wicked and the false
and the you know the standards that the
left is pushing on us if we don't have
good true standards to strive toward our
society is going to decay that's what's
going on around us and and a society
that allows itself to do that is quite
irrational indeed i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knoll show i'll see
you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022. on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show